this is the biggest bartending
competition in the country it's
aggressive it's a very aggressive dog
but one of us is gonna go on to win the
whole thing is definitely much unique
drink in the night it's a dream come
true we have the list we need absolute
silence I'm gonna work harder now
literally I'm excited to see what
happens
so the morning after the semifinals they
call a meeting for the top 10 at 8:30 in
the morning which is ludicrous for any
bartender congratulations on making it
to the final 10 today's challenges are
going to test your bartending skills and
your imagination so you guys are gonna
have to create a new drink and if that
wasn't challenging enough tonight you're
gonna have to make enough for four
judges and 400 consumers the first thing
that went through my head was in red
letters in all capitals f you see okay
and not only do we have to make a brand
new drink but we have to batch it out
for 400 people I mean that's a ton of
syrup that's fun more ingredients it was
kind of a bombshell the first part of
today's final guys is the taste
challenge you guys are gonna have to
deconstruct a cocktail we've made
previously person who wins actually gets
a ten minute consultation with the 2012
the most imaginative bartender
who knows the ins and outs of the entire
competition he had to do all of this
before 10 minutes with him really adds
to what you can attribute to the
competition they had blindfolds out
paper and set us down last year's
national winner made us a cocktail that
we couldn't see we had to guess as many
ingredients in the drink as possible my
phone's off please I was not prepared to
drink a cocktail at 9:30 in the morning
everybody has their cocktails so make
sure to smell and taste the cocktail it
was just a really tough challenge in the
morning especially after a night in
traffic thirty more seconds I knew there
was pineapple I knew there was lemon
juice but after that I wasn't sure so I
couldn't quite figure out the flavor of
what else was coming through okay guys
so blindfolds off you now have one
minute so write down as many ingredients
as you can recognize it like I've really
hated that word as soon as we took the
blindfolds off I could tell that there
are a few people in the room that knew
exactly what it was everybody we're
gonna collect those we're gonna tally up
the scores I bombed it because I was not
prepared I had a bunch of citrus before
my palate wasn't cleanse winning the
taste challenge would be huge
can anybody tell us what the actual
drink was the interesting thing about
the Singapore sling is it has many many
variations
everybody did a really great job but we
did have a standout winner Julio Cabrera
from Miami congratulations he is
probably the best professional bartender
in the country it is a prize to talk to
Nathan because he's super nice he's a
great guy having ten minutes with Nathan
would have been crucial so you guys all
now have a chance to work on your
cocktail recipes for today you're gonna
have two hours to run around you can
have a khari she can have $300 you can
go anywhere you want in Vegas but just
remember you have to get it all done in
two hours
recommend just raiding Whole Foods is it
the best scenario no that's why it's a
challenge yeah so the idea is that
you're creating the cocktail in your
mind now and you have to follow that for
the rest of the day I would never make a
drink on paper that I couldn't practice
before I served it someone else okay
I have this amount of time I have these
ingredients available and I have two
hours to do this what is possible
overall shopping was a pretty intense
situation had two hours to go to get the
produce that I needed I was rushing
around like a crazy person trying to get
all of the perfect pairs and I wasn't
quite sure what my garnish was gonna be
I just wanted to make sure that the
grapefruits are firmed because when you
slice grapefruits you don't want it to
fall apart upon slicing simplicity got
me in the finals hopefully simplicity
will carry me through to number one they
didn't have the exact cider that I
wanted
I needed ten bottles of cider there were
only eight okay how do I make this work
I need to get in touch with someone that
works here I need do you have any more
of these anywhere I took all the ones
off the show it's this Crispin overall
shopping was a pretty intense situation
I had two hours I made it back when I
got back to the venue for the
competition
wheeled all my stuff up all of that
excitement all of the fun that I was
experiencing at Whole Foods and the
night before that was opening it was
tense it was serious everybody had their
work hats on is
this is the competition if you're
nervous tonight
this is your last chance to get
everything perfect to win this
competition
these are going to do the hardest judges
that could ever judge me this right now
is the competition whatever they're
drinking super-nervous ranges the
preparation no idea